the
crisis at the border is supposed to play
well for democrats that was the idea
you're going to open it up the poor
oppressed insert whatever foreign nation
in the world is pouring over our border
we've got to let them across we're the
cause of all their problems and we
we're such a terrible country and that's
why we've got to let them into
our terrible country and we owe it to
them and we
we're the only nation on earth that
shouldn't have borders so knock all of
them down and i think the american
people are sick of that i think it that
doesn't work and so the main way that
the left tries to
gin up this kind of division is through
race hustling
and in this case because it's a bunch of
haitians pouring over the border how did
they get here i don't know i you know i
know that the biden administration
jensaki is saying that they don't plan
to stay very long and yeah they the
haitians just made it all the way over
to mexico and then they're running
across the border just for a long
weekend away or something but but
because they're haitian now you have an
added element of of black lives matter
right these are black people and so
obviously the only reason to keep
foreigners out of our country is because
they're black so al sharpton
the
the race hustler
par excellence left in our country flies
down to the border and he and he starts
to give one of his stupid race hustling
lectures
but he's not as well received down there
in texas as he often is actually he gets
heckled while giving his extremely dumb
remarks
[Music]
nobody wants to hear your
wow you know i didn't expect to hear
such common sense remarks in that speech
i wasn't hearing it from al sharpton i
was hearing it from the hecklers in
texas and it's true al sharpton is a
disgrace i mean he's been a hustler and
a pimp his entire career he launched his
career on a rape hoax the tijuana
brawley hoax virtually everything else
the guy's been involved in is a hoax and
it's just a shakedown so that any time
he can claim some sort of
racial offense he can he can shake down
corporations and local communities and
enrich himself
frankly i i had a greater deal of
respect for al sharpton back when he was
a big fat guy wearing those expensive
pinstriped suits
just walking around new york shaking
people down like the mobster that he is
now that he looks like a shriveled up
little raisin and he's wearing his kind
of more you know put together a higher
higher class more muted uh you know
little vest and his little his little
nice shirt i don't know it doesn't
doesn't play as well to me it's sort of
sad and i don't think the american
people are really buying it either i'm
so glad you like that clip but hold on
i need you to go over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher wherever
you get your podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-l-e-s
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five-star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]